Nous allons reprendre cette série d'études sur la création, sur la confession de foi baptistes en 1689,
les chapitres sur la création.
La première, et même, ça reste, la plus grande emphase que j'aimerais mettre, c'est de nous rappeler,
nos études utilisent pour base la confession.
Je vous rappelle que la confession, c'est un document qui cherche à représenter la manière historique
dont l'Église a préservé un fil conducteur incassable d'interprétation biblique dès sa jeunesse jusqu'à nos jours.
Voilà pourquoi les confessions sont importantes.
C'est car les confessions, elles cherchent, au long de l'histoire, à confirmer ce que l'Église a toujours proclamé
comme en étant la vérité, la correcte interprétation de la Bible, une interprétation protégée par les temps,
pour empêcher qu'une Église, aujourd'hui, porte des innovations dans sa manière d'interpréter la Bible,
pour nous assurer que par un respect des critères bibliques d'interprétation,
l'Église, au long de l'histoire, même si on a eu à chaque génération des hérésies, des déviations, des fausses enseignements,
on a toujours cherché à défendre la vérité par des documents confessionnels, par des conseils, etc.
Donc la confession baptiste des fois de 1689, elle a été faite comme un travail par la suite du travail des réformateurs,
dans les générations qui ont suivi, couplée à l'assemblée de Westminster, quelque part,
qui était un document qui a précédé, et les baptistes réformés, ils ont bien sûr retravaillé très peu de points à cet égard.
Donc l'objectif c'était de porter dans ces documents ce qui était l'interprétation classique de toutes les phases de l'histoire de l'Église,
de toute Église légitime qui protégeait la vérité.
Et donc ils rassemblent dans la confession les doctrines principales et capitales de la foi.
Par exemple la doctrine sur les Écritures, si on n'est pas d'accord, comme les catholiques n'étaient pas d'accord,
en réclamant l'inspiration du pape, ils étaient en même temps en train d'annuler l'autorité absolue et suprême des Écritures.
Et donc c'est une correction qu'on porte.
L'important c'est qu'il y a toujours été dans l'histoire, depuis la période du Nouveau Testament,
la vision de ce qui est la Bible et les faits qu'elle est à l'autorité suprême.
Donc quand on considère la confession et qu'on arrive à la doctrine de la création,
pourquoi c'est une insistance principale pendant tous ces cours sur les chapitres 4
que l'interprétation littérale des Genèses est une question confessionnelle.
C'est pour insister que pendant 2000 ans d'histoire presque, jusqu'à ce qu'on n'arrive pas à la popularisation de la théorie de l'évolution,
c'est la popularisation d'une théorie qui a été commercialisée et vendue et enseignée comme si c'était plus robuste qu'elle n'est,
comme si les évidences qui auraient pu corroborer cette théorie étaient fortes,
lorsque les évidences scientifiques qui corroborent la théorie biblique sont beaucoup plus fortes.
Malheureusement, par la popularisation, par la sécularisation, cela a eu un impact dans l'Église plus récente.
Et plusieurs églises ont développé des méthodes d'interprétation biblique
qui sont contraires aux méthodes bibliques historiques d'interprétation.
Donc, de dire que l'interprétation littérale des Genèses est une question confessionnelle,
cela a un poids très fort.
C'est-à-dire que pendant presque 2000 ans d'histoire,
toutes les générations de l'Église ont toujours abordé Genèse,
au moins toutes les églises légitimes et orthodoxes ont toujours abordé Genèse de manière littérale,
en prenant par exemple les six jours littéraux des créations.
Et quand on considère non seulement la création de l'univers,
c'est la première partie des paragraphes 1,
nous devons affirmer ce que la Bible et l'Église ont toujours affirmé dans l'histoire.
Et on a défendu cela de manière historique et surtout biblique.
On arrive à un exode chapitre 20,
en fait, on a Dieu lui-même qui parle en disant,
car en six jours, Dieu a créé toutes les choses.
Voilà pourquoi tu travailleras six jours et un jour tu auras du repos.
Donc, si Dieu lui-même interprète Genèse de manière littérale,
personne ne pourrait le faire autrement,
sans faire de la violence contre la parole de Dieu.
Donc, il y a beaucoup d'ignorance d'un côté dans l'Église d'aujourd'hui,
vis-à-vis à la science elle-même.
On a l'impression qu'il y a plus d'évidence scientifique qu'il n'y a pas.
Mais de l'autre côté, c'est un sacrifice qui coûte très cher
de ne pas traiter Genèse de manière littérale.
Donc, voilà pourquoi il y a cette insistance,
non seulement par rapport aux implications théologiques
et même en vue du salut,
car l'Écrit lui-même est présenté comme les nouvelles Adam
et l'Écrit lui-même interprète Genèse comme littéral et historique.
Et il y a de l'impact même pour les saluts.
Mais il y a aussi des impacts très clairs
par rapport à la compréhension de ce qu'il y a à l'être humain.
Car l'anthropologie,
quand on voit toute la complexité de l'être humain
dans sa constitution d'une portion spirituelle,
d'une portion personnelle,
qui ne trouvera jamais dans la théorie de l'évolution
une explication satisfaisante,
car si nous sommes les fruits d'une énergie qui ne pense pas,
qui n'a pas de sentiments, qui n'est pas personnel,
pour être cohérent avec cette théorie d'origine,
c'est que les philosophes du nihilisme,
de l'existentialisme de nos jours suggèrent,
c'est de supprimer cette soif qu'on a pour avoir du sens,
cette soif qu'on a pour justifier les demandes d'amour,
d'éternité, de moralité
et tous les relativismes qui viennent avec.
Et donc la réalité, c'est que
qui est le plus capable de traiter les problèmes de l'homme,
d'expliquer ce que l'homme est.
Donc les crises principales de l'homme sont
cette soif pour joie, pour bonheur,
qu'on n'arrive jamais à trouver,
c'est les vies des dieux.
Dieu nous a créés pour lui,
c'est qu'il est lui qui peut remplir.
Et la crise morale, la coupabilité,
de vivre la vie sans paix.
L'addiction à des petits plaisirs
qui n'arrivent jamais à combler les vides,
d'un côté,
et de l'autre côté, la coupabilité,
la crise morale de l'homme.
Savoir qu'il est très noble à plusieurs égards,
mais en même temps très cruel à plusieurs égards.
Et comment chercher à traiter l'être humain ?
Est-ce qu'il nous semble tout simplement
les restes d'une évolution animale ?
Et voilà pourquoi nous sommes encore
assez bestiales dans nos traitements.
D'où vient la guérison pour ces crises ?
Quelle est la solution ?
Supprimer la coupabilité ?
Dire qu'on doit suivre nos désirs,
nos passions ?
Donc la réalité, c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de traitements
qui nous sont présentés aujourd'hui
sur la base d'une vision des mondes
qui s'est écartée de la conception essentielle
de ce qui est allait être humain.
On ne pourrait même pas défendre
les droits des hommes
de manière cohérente
selon les philosophies actuelles,
selon les visions des mondes actuels,
car si l'homme n'a pas
son importance sacrée enracinée
sur le fait qu'il a été créé
l'image des dieux,
il n'y a aucune justificative
à partir d'une énergie
pour chercher à protéger
ou reconnaître la valeur
des êtres humains.
Donc la réalité, c'est que
quand on parle de l'anthropologie,
de l'anthropologie biblique,
c'est là où on va voir
comment nous sommes plus en mesure
de comprendre qui nous sommes,
quel est le but de notre existence,
quelle est notre signification,
quelle est notre maladie,
quelles sont nos demandes
qui peuvent vraiment nous satisfaire
au lieu, à nouveau,
de consacrer des heures
et des heures de psychanalyse
ou prendre des psychotropes
dans nos jours,
des médicaments
qui cherchent à camufler
les symptômes
mais qui n'arrivent jamais
à traiter l'homme
comme il faut
car on ne connaît pas
l'homme
tel que la Bible
le révèle.
En abandonnant
l'interprétation
littérale
de jeunesse,
on a vu l'impact
non seulement
sur les six jours
littérales
de création,
terre vieille
ou terre jaune,
mais on a vu aussi
dans l'Église
grandir
la dilution
de ce qui va démarquer
ce qui est l'être humain
et la manière biblique
de traiter l'âme humaine.
Psyché signifie
âme,
c'est un terme biblique.
Et à nouveau,
pendant 2000 ans d'histoire,
les médecins
de l'âme
n'étaient pas
les psychologues,
les psychanalystes,
les médecins de l'âme
étaient les biblicistes,
si on peut dire comme ça.
Et c'est comme ça
qu'on doit prendre
en considération
par exemple
la crise actuelle
de l'homme
et la femme
qui ont été créées
dès le départ
comme complémentaires,
comme quelque chose
très important
pour comprendre
ce qui nous sommes
en tant qu'image des dieux
et aujourd'hui,
cela est renversé
même à l'Église,
même dans les mondes évangéliques.
Et tout,
si on revient en arrière,
peut déclencher
de l'interprétation
non littérale
au plus flexible
des Genèse,
en écoutant plus
la culture
et cherchant à adapter
la parole
à la culture.
Donc,
c'était pour montrer
la pertinence
surtout intrabiblique
qui est le point
le plus important
pour nous.
La Bible prend
très sérieusement
Genèse,
Apocalypse finie,
les deux derniers chapitres
comme on a vu,
avec l'emphase
sur l'arbre d'Avi
et la rivière
qui coule
dans les paradis célestes
en démontrant
qu'historiquement,
la création originale
était déjà
pour préfigurer
cette réalité.
Et donc,
l'histoire
telle que Dieu nous raconte
commence avec un terme
qui signifie
histoire,
Genèse,
quand on ouvre la Bible
et nous ne pouvons pas
prendre Genèse
comme non littéral
ou non historique.
Ok ?
Ça, c'est l'objectif.
Et donc,
on a avancé
pour considérer
la création de l'univers
comme étant
une création
fiat ex nivilu.
Ça signifie,
une création fiat
signifie
par la déclaration
de Dieu,
par les décrets de Dieu,
par la parole de Dieu.
Ex nivilu,
c'est à partir de rien,
sans aucun matériel
préexistant.
Ensuite,
on est passé
à considérer
les douzièmes
et les troisièmes
paragraphes
de la confession.
Je pense qu'on peut
les relire.
Pour les premiers
paragraphes
qui traitent
l'univers,
la confession nous dit
au commencement
et la pluie de Dieu,
père, fils
et saint-esprit,
pour la manifestation
de sa gloire
et de son éternelle puissance,
de sa sagesse
et de sa bonté,
de créer ou de faire
en six jours
les mondes
et tout ce qui se trouve,
choses visibles
et invisibles
et tout était très bon.
La création générale.
Et ensuite,
on passe à la considération
de la création de l'homme,
l'anthropologie.
Après avoir fait
toutes les autres créatures,
Dieu créa l'homme.
Il les créa
mâles et femelles
avec des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles
qui les rendaient
propres
à cette vie
avec Dieu
pour laquelle
ils avaient été créés.
Ils ont été faits
à l'image des dieux
en connaissance,
justice
et vraie sainteté,
ayant la loi des dieux
inscrite dans leur cœur
et les pouvoirs
de l'accomplir.
Ils avaient cependant
la possibilité
de la transgresser
puisqu'ils étaient laissés
à la liberté
de leur propre volonté
qui étaient capables
des changements.
Paragraphe 3.
En plus
de la loi
inscrite dans leur cœur,
ils ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas
manger de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal.
Tant qu'ils ont gardé
ces commandements,
ils ont été heureux
dans leur communion
avec Dieu
et ont dominé
sur toutes
les créatures.
Donc ici,
c'est la description
de l'état
original de l'homme
et de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme.
Donc,
ce qu'on a déjà considéré,
c'est que l'homme
a été créé
directement
par Dieu
d'une manière
spéciale
par rapport
au rythme
des jeunesses.
Donc,
Dieu créa
toutes les choses,
tout était bon
à chaque fois,
mais lorsqu'il
allait créer
l'être humain,
Dieu s'arrête,
il y a comme
un conseil trinitaire,
il y a une espèce
de progression
dans les textes bibliques,
il y a une pause
dans les textes bibliques
et là,
il y a cette déclaration
faisons l'homme
non selon son espèce,
ce qui était le cas
pour toutes les autres
créatures,
à nouveau,
sans aucune possibilité
d'évolution
car chaque animal,
chaque être vivant
a été créé
selon son espèce
et l'homme
n'a pas été créé
tout simplement
selon son espèce.
L'homme
a été créé
à l'image
et ressemblance
des dieux.
Donc,
c'était une création
spéciale.
Nous avons aussi
pris du temps
pour considérer
ce qui signifie
la constitution
de l'homme,
donc les composants
de l'homme.
Par exemple,
on a discuté un peu
sur l'origine de l'âme,
le fait que l'homme
est intégral,
inséparable
et qu'en même temps,
il est constitué
des éléments
d'une partie matérielle,
d'une partie non matérielle.
cette partie non matérielle
est appelée parfois
âme,
parfois esprit
et parfois
il y a une distinction
qui peut être faite
entre âme
et esprit.
Donc,
on a considéré
tout ça
et tout cela
nous aide à comprendre
qui nous sommes
et comment régler
nos problèmes.
Et ensuite,
on est passé
à considérer
ces cas
des plus importants
à propos
de l'être humain.
Donc,
c'est ce qui fait
la noblesse
de l'homme,
c'est ce qui fait
que l'homme vive
certaines crises
que les animaux
ne vivent pas
et la réalité,
c'est les plus grands
privilèges
et la plus grande
responsabilité.
L'homme a été fait
la couronne
de la création
pour être
image des dieux.
Donc,
image des dieux,
c'est quelque chose
que nous sommes
et comme nous sommes
image des dieux,
nous devons
faire,
comme image des dieux.
Donc,
c'est quelque chose
qui est au même temps
un grand privilège
et qui est au même temps
une grande responsabilité.
Nous sommes rédévables
devant Dieu
si nous sommes en train
d'accomplir
les buts de notre existence,
si nous sommes en train
de fonctionner
comme image des dieux.
Donc,
nous avons considéré
la semaine dernière
quelques vérités préalables
liées à la discussion
sur l'image des dieux
car, bien sûr,
la première chose
qu'il faut reconnaître,
c'est qu'il s'agit
d'un grand mystère
à nouveau.
La Bible,
elle est très claire
et catégorique
lorsqu'elle présente
l'homme
comme une image
des dieux.
Par contre,
de quelle manière
pouvons-nous identifier
avec précision
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme ?
C'est un peu compliqué
car nous savons
que Dieu
est infini
à tous égards
et donc cette image
n'est pas
une image exacte
en termes
de mesure
ou d'intensité.
Nous savons
qu'en tant
qu'image des dieux
à l'origine
on était parfait
et en même temps
nous savons
que nous ne pouvons
pas être image
des dieux
à tous égards.
Il y a certains attributs
qui Dieu possède
que nous ne possédons pas.
Nous possédons
l'immortalité
dérivée des dieux,
Dieu possède
l'éternité.
On a un point de départ,
on n'aura pas un point de fin
et donc à tous égards,
Dieu est dans
une intensité
infinie
de tous attributs
que nous pouvons retrouver
en nous
en tant que son image
et il y a aussi
certains attributs
des dieux
que nous ne allons pas
trouver dans l'être
au vent.
Donc il y a beaucoup
de discussions
à cet égard
pour essayer
de définir
ou par exemple
nous concentrer
pour considérer
quelle est l'image
des dieux dans l'homme.
Est-ce que c'est
à la création ?
après la chute ?
Est-ce que c'est
après la régénération ?
Ou est-ce que c'est
dans la glorification ?
Et on a considéré
même une cinquième option.
Est-ce que Dieu
avait créé Adam
à l'origine
à la création
Adam et Ève
déjà en se basant
sur l'image
du Christ
qui viendrait
incarner pour nous sauver
et s'est réglorifié
après ?
Donc on a considéré
plusieurs mystères
très intéressants
à cet égard.
Et donc
on a vu
qu'il n'y a pas
de différence
très significative
entre image
et rassemblance
mais je pense
qu'il faut revenir
au moins à l'illustration
car il y a
un poids
qui se porte plus
envers les reflets
d'un miroir
et il y a un poids
qui se porte plus
vers la question
des représentativités.
Ok ?
Donc
je vous ai rappelé
que nous sommes
image de Dieu
par rapport
à ce que nous sommes
nous sommes
l'image de Dieu
par rapport
à nos capacités
nos facultés
et nous sommes
image de Dieu
par rapport
à la manière
dont on doit agir
et donc
l'illustration
du miroir
est la meilleure
pour qu'on fonctionne
pour qu'on soit
image de Dieu
il faut qu'on soit
toujours devant Dieu
donc s'il y a
un miroir
pour que l'image
puisse être
les reflets
de quelqu'un
il faut que cette personne
soit devant
donc l'être humain
a été créé
pour vivre
devant Dieu
pour être toujours
dans cette connexion
avec Dieu
nous avons été fait
l'image de Dieu
avec un but
de contemplation
constante
vivre
corandéot
devant Dieu
ok
et même si
Dieu ne bouge pas
et nous sommes
image de Dieu
nous sommes
par être
image de Dieu
en même temps
quand on observe
les capacités
de Dieu
ou les facultés
nous observons
plusieurs attributs
qu'on appelle
communicables
en Dieu
et en nous
par exemple
on perçoit
que nous avons
autoconscience
raisonnement
sens de justice
moralité
nous
contemplons
cette
notion
de sainteté
nous sommes
des êtres
cultuels
qui s'éportent
vers l'adoration
de la divinité
et donc
dans toutes ces choses
nous percevons
qu'il y a
en nous
des capacités
des facultés
et même si
nous ne sommes pas
tout puissants
nous avons
des puissances
des capacités
de recréer
tout comme Dieu
a créé
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
nous sommes
image de Dieu
par rapport
à nos facultés
et
nous agissons
comme image de Dieu
lorsque nous faisons
les choses
donc là
si Dieu bouge
nous devons bouger
pour donner un exemple
Dieu a créé
l'homme
en tant que son image
en dehors du jardin
mais il a créé
l'homme
pour être son image
donc il a inséré
l'homme
dans les jardins
afin qu'il ait
un motif
des paramètres
c'est un jardin
que Dieu lui-même
avait cultivé
et l'homme
devait étendre
ses jardins
en prenant
cette matière primaire
qui était lémane
dans son état original
et développer
la sujet
etc
il y avait
des relations
intra-trinitaires
et Dieu a structuré
les relations humaines
de manière familiale
à l'image
de la trinité
et nous a créés
dans un environnement
marital
pour multiplier
avoir des enfants
et faire de la culture
donc nous allons
revenir sur ces points
mais c'est important
de remarquer
que par l'être
et les faire
nous sommes appelés
l'image des dieux
donc
les considérations
préalables
ont traité
plusieurs aspects
je pense qu'il faut
que j'ai révélé
juste sur
la distinction
entre ce qu'on appelle
l'image
du Christ
et notre image
donc nous sommes
quelque part
une copie des dieux
et l'écrit
c'est là
comme si c'était
la projection
elle-même
des dieux
quelque part
donc après avoir
autrefois
à plusieurs reprises
et de plusieurs manières
parlé à nos pères
par les prophètes
Dieu dans ces derniers temps
nous a parlé par les fils
qu'il a établi
héritier de toutes choses
par lesquels
il a aussi créé
les mondes
et qui étant
les reflets
de sa gloire
et l'emprunt
de sa personne
et soutenant
toutes choses
par sa parole puissante
à faire la purification
des péchés
et c'est assis
à la droite
de la majesté divine
dans les lieux
très hauts
devenus
d'autant supérieurs
aux anges
qu'il a hérité
un nom plus excellent
qu'il est leur
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
nous
pour plus
même dans la gloire
on sera
parfaitement
fait image
de Dieu
et image
de Christ
nous ne serons pas
image
de Dieu
tel que le Christ
est car Christ
est Dieu lui-même
et le Christ
incarné
et glorifié
devient donc
l'image
expresse
de Dieu
donc c'est là
c'est sur lui
sur qui nous basons
notre image
mais ce n'est pas
atteignable
de l'être
tel qu'il est
et l'autre
distinction importante
c'est la distinction
qu'on a traité
entre structure
et fonction
ou l'essence
qu'on appelle
plus étroit
de l'image
des dieux
et l'essence
plus large
de l'image
des dieux
donc c'est intéressant
quand on pense
au terme
étroit
ou large
pour définir
l'image
des dieux
et là
on fait la distinction
entre l'état
original
de l'homme
dans la création
il y a deux passages
là je vais juste
vous appeler
ouvrir
Ephésiens 3
il y a trois termes
qui nous utilisons
que les théologiens
utilisent
pour définir
ce qui devrait
être considéré
comme les noyaux
original
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
et ces trois termes
sont trouvés
en Ephésiens 3
pardon
4 23
désolé
j'ai
fait la confusion
entre les 4
et les 3
4 23
à 25
donc
à être
renouvelé
dans l'esprit
de votre intelligence
et à revêtir
l'homme nouveau
créer
selon Dieu
dans une justice
et une sainteté
qui produit
la vérité
et donc
ces trois termes
sont très importants
justice
sainteté
et vérité
donc lorsque les théologiens
essayent de définir
quel est vraiment
le soleil
à partir duquel
tous les rayons
de l'image des dieux
éclatent
dans l'homme
et à travers l'homme
c'est lorsqu'on considère
dans l'état
original
de l'homme
quelle était
sa création
essentielle
originale
et là
il y a ces trois termes
vérité
sainteté
et justice
ou droiture
et donc
quand on considère
ces trois termes
c'est intéressant
car on peut faire
la liaison
entre ce qu'on appelle
les trois offices
qu'on a connus
du Christ
et dans
la théologie réformée
particulièrement
les puritans
ils vont
mettre l'emphase
sur ce qui était
notre rôle
ces trois offices
intégrales
essentielles
de l'homme
donc la droiture
qui serait liée
à cette perfection
qu'on dirait
des puretés
envers la divinité
qui était
dans une complète
absence
d'aucun obstacle
pour notre relation
avec Dieu
et donc ça
renvoie à l'office
surtout du prêtre
donc les prêtres
il a été
insitué
quelle est la distinction
entre les sacrificateurs
qui Dieu a dû établir
pour sacrifier
ou pour voir
les sacrifices
pour nos péchés
et les Christ lui-même
les Christ
comme suprême
sacrificateur
il nous renvoie
à l'image
de ce qu'on devrait être
c'est qu'on était
avant la chute
à l'édan
ceux qui avaient
les privilèges
de vivre cette vie
devant Dieu
en intimité
avec Dieu
tous les jours
et particulièrement
les sabbats
dans cette rencontre
avec Dieu
et donc
dans cette considération
des droits
de surparfaites
nous voyons
comment les Christ
est le seul
qui a pu faire
ces sacrifices
d'une fois pour toutes
est rentré
dans les sanctuaires
célestes
car il était
le seul
sacrificateur
sans péché
et donc la réalité
c'est que
notre vie
donc lequel
qui est parlé
il est un type
déjà d'église
déjà des sanctuaires
dans les mondes
original
Dieu a créé
un lieu
pour être
les lieux
des dieux
avec son peuple
lorsque son peuple
était dans un état
original
donc là
l'essentiel pour nous
c'est que Dieu
nous a créés
pour être des prêtres
des personnes
qui ont l'accès
à la présence
des dieux
et qui ont accès
à la présence
des dieux
à cause de cette justice
de cette droiture
originale
ensuite
les théologiens
vont mettre l'emphase
sur
les mots
vérités
pour mettre
en relève
les rôles
des prophètes
et donc là
c'est intéressant
les jardins
devraient être
gardés
quelque part
et ce qui devrait
être gardé
était particulièrement
la vérité
donc Dieu
qui va mettre
l'emphase
sur le fait
que simplement
la manière
dont Adam
était capable
de reconnaître
la vérité
dans son état
original
et de nommer
tous les animaux
de la manière
correcte
de manière intelligente
c'est la capacité
que Dieu nous a donné
essentielle
et originale
de reconnaître
la vérité
interpréter
et avoir
surtout
la responsabilité
et la rédivabilité
de protéger
la vérité
préserver
de Dieu
d'agir
comme prophète
dans les mondes
créés
c'est à dire
lorsqu'on était
ou on serait
exposé
aux serpents
c'était
l'obligation
majeure
d'Adam et Ève
de protéger
la vérité
préserver
proclamer
la vérité
et c'est
notamment là
où ils ont échoué
en suivant
les mensonges
de Satan
et voilà pourquoi
les Christ
quand il va porter
la rédemption
il va s'accrocher
à la vérité
lorsqu'il sera tenté
par les diables
dans les déserts
donc ça c'est la responsabilité
de tous êtres humains
et ça reste notre responsabilité
l'une des responsabilités
les plus essentielles
et primaires
c'est notre attachement
aux lois des dieux
à la parole des dieux
et notre capacité
de reconnaître
la vérité
c'est intéressant
car dans son essence
c'était la définition
la plus étroite
de l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
donc justice
vérité
et sainteté
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment même
après la chute
même si les êtres humains
n'ont plus
la capacité
d'agir
envers
cette essence
de manière correcte
l'être humain
est esclave
du mensonge
dans sa condition
les athées disent
que Dieu n'existait pas
mais Paul
il va démontrer clairement
qu'ils sont inexcusables
car au fond de leur cœur
de leur conscience
ils savent
reconnaître Dieu
et donc
ce qu'ils déclarent
n'est pas authentique
n'est pas véritable
la réalité
c'est une déclaration
contraire à toute évidence
qu'ils ont la capacité
de reconnaître
donc les non-chrétiens
ils ont la capacité
de reconnaître la vérité
mais leur cœur
les empêche
de les faire
leur cœur corrompu
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
mais dans l'état original
on avait cette capacité
de fonctionner
comme prophète
de manière très essentielle
il y a aussi la notion
de sainteté
qui renvoie
à ces
à ces rôles
qui avaient
les rois d'Israël
particulièrement
les rois pieux
qui avaient Israël
qui étaient
la royauté sainte
la sainte royauté
et là c'est pour
reproduire
pour dominer
dans les mondes
pour sous-juger
les mondes
des manières
à reproduire
la gloire des dieux
donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans la bible
quand on pense
à la gloire des dieux
il y a cette notion
tout simplement
des beautés
la beauté
béatifique
des dieux
dans une contemplation
de sa sainte beauté
dans la beauté
de sa sainteté
mais
en même temps
la gloire
elle est
souvent liée
et presque
essentiellement
liée
à la position
du roi
et donc à chaque fois
quand on voit
les contextes
des rois
on pense à la gloire
des certains rois
la gloire du roi
solomon
etc
ou lorsqu'Esaïe
va avoir
cette vision
du trône des dieux
du temple
des dieux remplis
il va voir
comment la gloire
de Dieu
va remplir
tous les temples
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
nous on a été appelé
non seulement
pour aller
envers les mondes
et reconnaître
la gloire des dieux
dans les mondes
mais nous
sommes appelés
à gouverner
les mondes
et agir
dans les mondes
de manière
par notre
interaction
avec la terre
la culture
l'interaction
avec les autres
êtres humains
l'interaction
en cherchant
à respecter
les lois des dieux
avoir les ailes
pour promouvoir
les lois des dieux
et produire
gouverner
de manière
à extraire
les mieux
de cette terre
pour rendre
gloire à Dieu
et donc nous
en tant qu'être humain
on a été fait
quelque part
pour avoir
la capacité
de reconnaître
la gloire des dieux
en tant que roi
et reproduire
les lois des dieux
en tant que petits rois
dans la terre
et des manières
que non seulement
on ait la capacité
de louer Dieu
mais des manières
à rendre Dieu
plus adorable
par nos oeuvres
faire tout
pour la gloire des dieux
donc l'être humain
n'a pas
que les privilèges
la capacité
d'adorer Dieu
mais il a la responsabilité
la responsabilité
de rendre Dieu
plus adorable
c'est pas qu'il soit
qu'il n'est l'est
mais c'est que Dieu
nous a fait
en tant que son image
pour que par nos oeuvres
les mondes
puissent voir
combien glorieux il est
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc c'est par
cette relation
qu'on voit
donc les fonctions
essentielles de l'homme
sont liées à ces trois offices
pardon
les lettres essentielles
avec ces fonctions
essentielles originales
et il y a la distinction
donc entre étroit
et large
dans ce sens là
donc pour ceux
qui on considère
comme étroit
c'est lorsqu'on se rapporte
à l'origine
avant la chute
et la pleine pureté
de ces trois offices
qu'on exerçait
d'accord ?
et quand on pense
à la notion plus large
de l'image des dieux
ça va passer
par quelques facultés
qu'on va considérer
comme personnalité
intellect
moralité
spiritualité
et plusieurs autres éléments
mais là
l'essence
de la pureté
elle n'était qu'à la création
on fait aussi
la distinction
entre structure
et fonction
c'est à dire
ce que l'homme est
et ce que l'homme fait
et là
on a déjà parlé
pas mal
sur
les deux possibilités
au long de l'histoire
de l'église
certains ont mis
plus d'emphase
comme si l'image des dieux
était plus centrée
sur la structure
de l'homme
sur ce qu'il est
d'autres
plus sur sa fonction
ce qu'il fait
ok
lorsque Dieu va dire
allez dominer
sur tous les animaux
etc
la réalité
c'est que nous
n'avons pas les droits
de séparer
car dans les contextes
bibliques
ces deux choses
vont toujours ensemble
et l'homme
il est l'image des dieux
il agit comme image des dieux
mais pour être plus précis
dans la considération
nous allons
à partir de maintenant
considérer
même si on ne veut pas
faire une séparation
rigide
une rupture rigide
c'est intéressant
de voir
de manière
plus précise
qu'est-ce qui peut
être considéré
comme partie
structurelle
de l'image des dieux
en nous
et qu'est-ce qui est
notre appel
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
en fait
en tant qu'image des dieux
dans les mondes
et donc
pour cela
je vais vous lire
voilà
une portion
d'Antoni Roekema
qui a écrit
un livre
très important
sur l'image des dieux
je vais vous citer
pour qu'on ait
un peu plus
la notion
entre la relation
entre l'aspect
suturel
et l'aspect
fonctionnel
de l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
donc il dit
au début
dans l'histoire
de la théologie
l'image des dieux
était considérée
comme les capacités
intellectuelles
et rationnelles
de l'homme
comme l'une
des caractéristiques
les plus importantes
sinon la plus importante
de l'image des dieux
dans les sens larges
donc intellectuelles
et rationnelles
bien sûr
l'image inclut
sensibilité morale
de l'homme
sa capacité
de distinguer
bien du mal
sa conscience
elle inclut également
la capacité
de rendre
en culte religieux
ce que Calvin
appelait
les sens des dieux
les sens divinitatis
ou les sens de la divinité
la sémence de la religion
une qualité humaine
importante
fréquemment mentionnée
par les théologiens
plus récemment
est celle
de la responsabilité
la capacité
de l'homme
à répondre
à Dieu
et à ses semblables
et la responsabilité
par rapport
à la manière
dont il rend
ses réponses
donc action
et réaction
et dans nos interactions
donc la conscience
que les êtres humains
ont en tous lieux
qui sont responsables
qui sont rédévables
qu'ils allons rendre compte
nous pourrions mentionner
bien d'autres capacités
ou qualités
telles que
les pouvoirs
volitionnels
de l'homme
c'est-à-dire la volonté
et la capacité
de prendre des décisions
une autre qualité
c'est celle
qu'on appelle
esthétique
par lesquelles
les êtres humains
non seulement
peuvent apprécier
la beauté
des dieux répandus
sous sa création
mais peuvent aussi
créer la beauté
artistique
par eux-mêmes
la peinture
la sculpture
la poésie
la musique
en fait
les dons
de la parole
et du chant
sont également
des qualités
de l'homme
qui appartiennent
à cette sphère
en vérité
nous pourrions
allonger cette liste
bien davantage
donc dans les sens
plus larges
l'image des dieux
c'est tout ce qui nous
distingue clairement
des animaux
tout ce qui fait
la noblesse
de l'homme
et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir
les rapports entre dieux
et l'homme
dans toutes ses capacités
donc il continue
le dit
dans toutes ses capacités
l'homme est semblable
à dieu
et par conséquent
l'image des dieux
en lui
se reflète
les pouvoirs
rationnels
de l'homme
reflètent
la raison
des dieux
et permet
à l'homme
dans un certain sens
de penser
les pensées
des dieux
après lui
la sensibilité morale
de l'homme
reflète quelque chose
de la nature morale
de l'homme
pardon
la sensibilité morale
de l'homme
reflète quelque chose
de la nature morale
des dieux
qui est suprême
et détermine
les biens et les mal
notre capacité
à avoir une relation
avec dieux
dans l'adoration
reflète la communion
que les pères
les fils
et les saints esprits
partagent entre eux
notre capacité
à répondre à dieu
et à nos semblables
imite la capacité
et la volonté
de dieux
de répondre
à nos prières
notre capacité
à prendre des décisions
reflète
dans une certaine mesure
les pouvoirs
suprêmes
des directions
de celui
qui accomplit tout
selon les conseils
et sa volonté
prendre des décisions
et celui
qui prend
toutes les décisions
notre sens
de la beauté
est une faible
réflexion
des dieux
qui répand
la beauté
abondamment
sur des sommets
couronnés
des neiges
des vallées
ornées
des lacs
et des couchers
de soleil
impressionnants
notre don
de la parole
est une imitation
de celui
qui nous parle
constamment
à la fois
dans son monde
et dans sa parole
et notre don
du chant
fait écho
à dieux
qui se réjouit
sur nous
avec des chants
tels qu'ils trouvaient
en sophonie 3.17
donc c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
cette complexité
que l'homme présente
et qui est complètement
distincte
de toute la création
donc quand on considère
la structure de l'homme
c'est que nous sommes
dans notre structure
essentielle
dans notre être
si vous voulez
que je vous pointe
de manière plus spécifique
les composants
les plus cités
dans les théologies
c'est l'invisibilité
c'est très intéressant
considérer par exemple
moi j'ai déjà
eu ces conversations
avec mes enfants
donc nous savons
que nous avons
une partie visible
qui est l'écor
mais nous avons
une partie invisible
et nous sommes conscients
parfois
que si nous nous retirons
ici de cette salle
là on a l'impression
qu'en regardant
les visages de chacun
en sortant
on va bien se rappeler
la Bible nous dit
qu'on ne se rappelle
même pas de notre
propre visage
quand on s'éloigne
du miroir
mais la réalité
c'est que
la racine
de notre identité
de ce que nous sommes
elle est au-delà
de l'aspect visible
et donc cet aspect
de l'invisibilité
de l'âme humaine
cet aspect
qui se porte aussi
envers l'immortalité
c'est quelque chose
qui nous renvoie
à la considération
de ces dieux
qui est invisible
les capacités
et facultés
qu'on appelle
psychologiques
c'est-à-dire
de l'âme
qui ont leur siège
dans l'âme
la rationalité
la moralité
la conscience
la complexité
émotionnelle
la volonté
l'autoconscience
l'autodétermination
les jugements
l'analyse
la complexité
des langages
la communication
et l'aspect
relationnel
ou la personnalité
donc nous sommes
des êtres
qui sont
différents
non seulement
en termes
d'intensité
des facultés
que les autres
êtres créés
ont
mais nous avons
certaines qualités
qui sont
complètement uniques
exclusives
aux êtres humains
et celles
qui sont
et qui trouvent
sa racine
dans l'image
de Dieu
il y a
ce qu'on appelle
l'intégrité
morale
et intellectuelle
qu'on a déjà
considéré
à l'origine
justice
vérité
intégrité
et même
après la chute
la capacité
d'apprécier
ce qui est juste
ce qui est moral
et la coupabilité
devant
l'incapacité
d'être juste
aucun être humain
n'échappe
à cette coupabilité
pour plus qu'il essaie
de se convaincre
ou de supprimer
cette coupabilité
et donc
même lorsqu'on considère
les corps
qui fait partie
de la structure
de l'être humain
il y a des débats
dans la théologie
pour Calvin
les sièges
de l'image des dieux
c'est l'âme
bien sûr
les cœurs
et ces rayons
peuvent se refléter
même à travers les corps
mais il y a
deux possibilités
de considérer les corps
comme composants
de l'image
essentielle des dieux
et notamment
car dans les contextes
des genèses
la Bible dit
que Dieu a créé
l'homme
à son image
et elle décrit
la manière
dont Dieu a créé
l'homme
et donc on sait
que d'un côté
si on considère
que Dieu
nous avait déjà créé
pour les bonnes œuvres
un Christ
avant la fondation du monde
comme nous dit
l'apôtre Paul
c'est possible
que Dieu
nous ait créé déjà
en envisageant
les Christ
qui viendraient
et là
les corps
seraient à l'image
du Christ
ok glorifié
de l'autre côté
même si
on ne veut pas
faire ce type
d'abordage
pour ne pas rentrer
dans beaucoup
de confusion
chronologique
nous pouvons considérer
que pour fonctionner
en tant qu'image
des dieux
l'être humain
il a besoin du corps
et donc les corps
est ce que Dieu
a créé
et donné
à l'homme
de manière appropriée
à servir
comme véhicule
d'expression
sans lesquelles
on ne peut pas
fonctionner
en tant qu'image
des dieux
et là
ça rentrerait
plutôt
dans l'aspect
fonctionnel
de l'homme
donc les corps
ont des fonctionnalités
des capacités
qui finissent
par
pour comporter
ses puissances
donc
je ne veux pas dire
que nous ne pouvons pas
créer des choses
par la parole
car
je crois vraiment
que
les Saint-Esprit
en faisant usage
des choses qu'on dit
et
l'impact
pour la construction
même émotionnelle
ou psychologique
des personnes
qui nous entourent
nous pouvons construire
ou détruire
Jacques
il va dans sa direction
pour dire
que nous pouvons détruire
toutes les choses
par la parole
et nous pouvons même
en faisant usage
d'autres outils
aujourd'hui
dire des choses
à un ordinateur
par exemple
et il construit
quelque chose
pour nous
mais la réalité
c'est que
Dieu a la capacité
de créer
Ex Nihilu
par sa parole
vous êtes avec moi
mais nous en fait
on va communiquer
les puissances créatrices
aussi
plutôt par la puissance
qui nous avons
dans nos membres
dans les corps
aimer Dieu
de tout notre coeur
de toute notre pensée
de toute notre âme
et de toutes nos forces
et là c'est vraiment
notamment
c'est que Dieu
nous a désigné
pour fonctionner
en tant que son image
c'est de prendre plaisir
dans son adoration
pleine
par tous ses moyens
donc c'est ça
que c'est très intéressant
quand on pense
à l'adoration
ou à la prière
par exemple
pour certains
il faut toujours prier
à genoux
pour d'autres
il faut toujours prier
en criant
et la réalité
c'est que
nos cordes vocales
et nos expressions
corporales
devraient être
en parfaite harmonie
avec nos ressentis
nos émotions
informées
par la vérité
l'inséparabilité
de l'homme
et donc il y aura
des prières
où je dois prier
à genoux
ou même allonger
des supplications
Jésus
il a prié
de plusieurs formes
différentes
car ça
c'est harmonique
et cohérent
avec l'urgence
des prières
la nature
ou d'adoration
ou des louanges
est-ce qu'on doit
toujours faire
des chants
des joies
et mettre nos mains
en haut
et crier
très fort
non
mais si nous ne le faisons
jamais
il y a quelque chose
qui ne va pas
vous comprenez
et donc la réalité
c'est que si nous prenons
plaisir légitimement
dans les vérités
qu'on chante
envers les vrais dieux
qui nous écoutent
là on est en train
de vivre la réalité
de cette vie
d'adoration
qui traverse
aussi nos corps
nos corps
sont un véhicule
d'expression
qui démontrent
combien on est en train
d'apprécier notre Dieu
prendre plaisir en Dieu
et qui sont utilisés
pour reproduire
la gloire des dieux
par les choses
qu'on fait
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc les corps
il y a aussi
quelque chose
qui est très
important et essentiel
pour que l'homme
puisse être
l'image des dieux
et fonctionner
comme l'image des dieux
et bien sûr
qu'en ce sens là
la complémentarité
qui n'est pas
réduite
ça c'est très important
de dire
au corps
car avec toute la folie
de l'identité des genres
aujourd'hui
on voit quelques chrétiens
qui se sentent
presque obligés
de défendre
la réalité
de la distinction
entre les sexes
qui est par les aspects
physiques ou biologiques
donc là
c'est clairement
quelque chose
qui est impossible
d'échanger
mais
la définition biologique
de l'homme
ou de la femme
elle nous donne
la certitude
que l'homme
aura
non seulement
un corps
d'homme
mais il aura
la structure
essentielle
émotionnelle
psychologique
d'un homme
et c'est dans cette
complémentarité
que nous allons retrouver
car c'est intéressant
la Bible nous parle
des distinctions
entre hommes
et femmes
qui vont au-delà
tout simplement
du corps
et elle nous parle
des rôles
qui sont parfaitement
en harmonie
et cohérents
avec la structure
émotionnelle
psychologique
de chacune des parties
les deux ont été créés
à l'image des dieux
les deux ne peuvent pas
occuper
la même position
avec le même type
de satisfaction
des qualités
les deux ne peuvent pas
recevoir
les mêmes coups
ça peut sonner
stéréotypique
de contempler
les réalités bibliques
mais quand on va
observer la réalité
ça finit
que les travaux
qui demandent
les plus
de la force physique
restent
dans sa majorité
exercée par les hommes
et que les femmes
doivent faire
certaines choses
qu'un homme
ne peut jamais le faire
et donc
c'est très important
pour nous
de nous rappeler
que quand on pense
à l'image des dieux
cette complémentarité
que dieux
a intentionnellement créée
elle est comprise
et explicite
dans ce qui signifie
l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
donc des bases
ça veut dire
que les êtres humains
sont relationnels
qu'ils ne peuvent pas
vivre isolement
mais au-delà
de la considération
tout simplement
de la pluralité
avec laquelle dieux
a créé l'humanité
il y a aussi
la complémentarité
donc chacun
possède
essentiellement
l'image des dieux
hommes et femmes
la même valeur
par contre
ils ont été créés
avec des distinctions
pour que dans
leur relation complémentaire
l'image des dieux
soit davantage affichée
on a des nuances
quand on arrive
dans la description
des polyphésiens 5
de la relation
entre les maris
et la femme
entre Christ
et l'église
que cette relation
a été projetée
déjà par dieux
avant la création
du monde
pour que les relations
maritales
puissent illustrer
la relation entre
Christ et l'église
nous devons apprendre
à respecter
ces paramètres
et donc
quand on pense
aux fonctions
là j'ai parlé
plutôt des lettres
essentielles
et donc l'image des dieux
comporte tous ces aspects
dont je viens de parler
car dans la description
biblique de la création
de l'homme
toutes ces choses
sont mentionnées
directes ou indirectement
et dans d'autres passages
qui parlent
de l'image des dieux aussi
donc il nous faut
connaître Dieu
bien connaître Dieu
pour nous connaître
ok
et il faut
connaître très bien
de la manière
dont Dieu nous a créés
donc c'est important
de considérer
quand on pense
aux fonctions
comment l'homme
fonctionne en tant
qu'image des dieux
donc dans les textes
de Genèse
qu'on a lu au départ
il y a
trois aspects
qui vont ressortir
comme les champs
d'actuation principales
à travers lesquels
l'être humain
sera en train
d'agir dans les mondes
comme image des dieux
comme représentation
des dieux
ok
donc ça
on définit
comme les trois mandats
en général
dans la théologie
on a
les mandats
qu'on appelle
culturels
c'est cet appel
que Dieu fait à l'homme
c'est la relation
de l'homme
avec la création
je vais faire par l'ordre
inverse d'importance
quelque part
mais les trois sont importants
et donc les mandats culturels
c'est la domination
de l'homme
sur la terre
ça fait référence
à la responsabilité
de l'homme
de cultiver la création
de façonner la culture
pour la gloire des dieux
donc à nouveau
prendre les motifs
les paramètres
du jardin des dents
et les reproduire
ça fait que l'homme
il va exercer
cette relation
les termes originales
donnent une idée
des
c'est pas
c'est des services
d'asservir la terre
dans quel sens
c'est pas
un exploit
violent
sans soin
au contraire
car Dieu
donne à l'homme aussi
la tâche
de garder
de préserver
ses jardins
et donc
c'est des fers
pour la gloire des dieux
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment
il y a
quelque part
dans toute la création
observable des dieux
malgré la chute
qui montre
que tout ce que Dieu
a créé
est beau
bon
généreux
est bon
est intelligent
et c'est quelque chose
qui est projeté
pour survivre
pour promouvoir la vie
c'est jamais
dans la direction
contraire
et l'être humain
devrait prendre
les modèles des dieux
en faisant usage
de son intelligence
du fait qu'il a
l'image des dieux
interagir avec la terre
et produire
des bonnes choses
produire des bonnes choses
développer la terre
donc là
c'est pas limité
tout simplement
à
la culture
de l'agriculture
mais
ça se développe
dans tous les champs
des connaissances
technologie
améliorer la vie
tel qu'on arrive
encore aujourd'hui
en partie
le problème c'est que
pendant qu'on avance
d'un côté
on est en temps
d'abuser en fait
de la relation
avec la terre
de l'autre côté
et donc c'est clair
que nous serons
responsables
et rélevables
mais l'homme
est appelé
à produire
les biens
en produisant
pour la nature
car
elle a été faite
par Dieu
pour produire
donc c'est à nous
d'organiser
d'extraire
et d'offrir
ces biens
pour la société
voilà pourquoi
les puritans
après la conversion
certains considèrent
comme des réveils
qu'ils ont vécu
mais il y a eu
plusieurs personnes
qui travaillaient
par exemple
avec la vente
des beaux vrages
des boissons
alcooliques
et qui ont délaissé
leur emploi
et donc là
c'est intéressant
plusieurs puritans
ils ont observé
que lorsqu'il
Paul
il dit
que c'est lui
qui dérobait
travaille avec
ses propres membres
pour avoir
du quoi
en faisant
ce qui est bon
ce qui est bien
pour pouvoir aider
ceux qui sont
dans les besoins
et donc là
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
non seulement
les mandats
de Dieu
c'est qu'on
n'aidera pas
mais qu'on travaille
avec ce qui produit
du bien
pour pouvoir
aussi avoir
la capacité
d'aider
ceux qui sont
dans les besoins
et donc juste
ça se développe
dans tous les sens
dans toutes les directions
dans toutes les ères
de l'être humain
où il peut
développer
de la culture
les villes
par exemple
il y a cette progression
aussi
la cité céleste
du futur
on commence
avec un jardin
on finira
avec une cité
et là
c'est important
car j'ai déjà entendu
certains chrétiens
qui tombent
sous l'influence
un peu
à la Rousseau
du bon sauvage
etc
et qui pensent
qu'il serait mieux
pour les chrétiens
de revenir
à une interaction
strictement rurale
avec la terre
etc
c'est à réfléchir
donc bien sûr
qu'il y a beaucoup
d'abus
il faut qu'on fasse
attention
à toutes les contaminations
qu'on voit aujourd'hui
mais en même temps
il faut savoir
que Dieu nous appelle
au développement
donc là
c'est aussi
quelque chose
d'important
à considérer
il y a aussi
les mandats sociaux
à quelque part
plus important
ce sont
les relations
entre les hommes
pas qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire envers les animaux
donc la domination
elle est plus liée
à la domination
envers les animaux
car c'est clair
que les animaux
avaient une puissance
et une force
qui surmontent
celle de l'homme
mais c'était
d'apprendre
à faire osage
des animaux
en les dominant
pas en les abusant
pas en les maltraitant
mais à service
de l'homme
avec intelligence
et ensuite
les sociales aussi
qui est
voilà
le respect
surtout
et la compréhension
de ce qu'on appelle
les complémentarités
donc la structure familiale
la cellule basique
de toute société
donc c'est important
car avant
que les sociétés
ne soient organisées
par une richesse commune
pour être appelée
un état
les communautés
se formaient
par un ensemble
des communautés familiales
des tribus
etc
et donc la famille
précède la société
et la société
elle a été faite
comme un comment
accord entre familles
et donc c'est très important
pour nous
de ne jamais permettre
que cela soit renversé
l'état veut nous donner
l'impression aujourd'hui
que c'est lui
qui a les droits
vers nos enfants
c'est l'école
et donc il faut
qu'on fasse attention
la réalité c'est que
la cellule fondamentale
de la société
c'est la famille
et donc les mandats sociaux
passent par toutes ces convictions
que la Bible nous apprend
de manière très riche
et qui est réduite
particulièrement
pour son bon exercice
pour son bon épanouissement
par cette relation
complémentaire
homme en tant qu'homme
femme en tant que femme
père en tant que père
mère en tant que mère
et relation
parent-enfant
telle que la Bible
nous enseigne
et c'est à partir de là
que les valeurs
seront promues
et préservées
donc là
il y a toutes les interactions
sociales aussi
que la Bible nous présente
envers les patrons
les emplois
etc.
il faut considérer
l'ensemble
mais il y a ces mandats
sociaux
qui passent par
multiplier
remplisser la terre
ok
développer
de la société
et les mandats
les plus importants
c'est les mandats
spirituels
les mandats
englobent non seulement
la responsabilité
de l'homme
d'obéir à Dieu
mais aussi la vocation
à cultiver
une relation profonde
avec lui
en lui offrant
adoration
et dépendance
en dépendance
de lui
donc c'est à dire
en ayant cette relation
d'adoration
et vivre constamment
même si on a eu
la capacité
de développer les choses
mais sachant
qu'ils nous sommes
complètement dépendants
de lui
il s'agit aussi
de trouver la satisfaction
en Dieu
en l'aimant
en nous réjouissant
lui
cela fait partie
intégrante
intrinsèque
de l'image
de Dieu
dans l'homme
donc on est appelé
à vivre en communion
avec notre créateur
à nouveau
en revient
à l'image
du miroir
devant Dieu
pour pouvoir
refléter son image
donc comment on peut
on va dire comme ça
nous énergiser
en tant que reflet
du soleil
des dieux
c'est en vivant
dans la contemplation
des dieux
dans toutes les ères
de nos vies
donc il faut garder
ces deux mots
en tant qu'image
des dieux
c'est les privilèges
des pouvoirs
je pense que
comme la Bible nous dit
que même toute la création
loue l'éternel
donc bien sûr
qu'ils ne sont pas
personnels
mais
j'ai
nous sommes convaincus
que toute la création
y compris les animaux
prennent plaisir
à l'ordre des dieux
un dieu lui-même
ils n'ont pas la capacité
d'adorer comme nous
nous avons des facultés
des capacités
d'apprécier
d'égoutter
on a un palais
qu'aucun être
n'a en fait
envers Dieu
et donc
lorsqu'il nous
qui avons été créés
pour
réjouir des dieux
avec un privilège
infiniment supérieur
à tous les autres animaux
prenons plaisir en Dieu
par l'adoration
par la contemplation
c'est infiniment plus naturel
de faire les choses
pour plaire à Dieu
donc la notion
corandéo
devant Dieu
elle s'éporte
surtout vers la notion
d'adoration
mais
impossible
que cela n'ait pas
des conséquences
envers toutes les aires
de la vie
donc les puritains
ils vivaient
toutes les espères
de la vie
par exemple
ils disaient
que pendant les persécutions
des dissidents
de la part
de la contre-réforme
je me dis comme ça
anglicaine
ils découvraient
qui était un puritain
en regardant
par exemple
dans les parties
dans une industrie
des bancs
la partie
qui était polie
lorsqu'il personne
ne verrait
donc on renverse
les bancs
on voit là
où personne
allait vérifier
si c'était bien fait
si c'était avec excellence
c'était un puritain
car il faisait tout
pour la gloire de Dieu
leur intégrité
la manière
dans leur interaction
au travail
il voulait
toujours
prendre conscience
qu'il devrait
adorer Dieu
faire tout
pour la gloire de Dieu
avec excellence
comme Joseph
il n'avait aucune idée
qu'il finirait
gouverneur d'Egypte
mais il a travaillé
avec excellence
en tant qu'esclave
en tant qu'est prisonnier
en tant qu'est
on va dire
un homme
en attendant
dans la maison
des potifards
il a toujours travaillé
avec excellence
car il faisait
pour Dieu
ok
et en même temps
dans les interactions
il savait
non seulement
qu'il devait
faire les choses
pour la gloire de Dieu
prenant plaisir
en Dieu
mais
il faisait
toutes les choses
en tant que représentant
de Dieu
car nous
c'est en rédevable
donc avant
d'avoir une réaction
envers
nos enfants
de nous demander
fruit de l'esprit
ok
c'est l'image des dieux
là dont on parle
est-ce que ça reflète
la patience
que Dieu exerce
envers moi
est-ce que ça reflète
!
la manière
dont je parle
devant mes enfants
tous les jours
murmure
ou
la joie
la paix
est-ce que je me montre
comme une personne anxieuse
je suis marqué
par la paix
qui se passe
toute intelligence
donc si nous sommes
enracinés
en Dieu
nos interactions
au travail
à l'école
à l'université
à la maison
dans toutes les sphères
de la vie
seront marquées
par cette grâce
et nous sommes
rédévables
nous sommes les représentants
des dieux
images des dieux
et donc les mandats
spirituels
bien sûr qu'ils passent
par les bonnes disciplines
spirituelles
dans les cadres
des jeunesses
c'est clair
que
toutes les soirées
il y avait
cette rencontre
et les samedis
étaient l'apogée
de la semaine
donc c'est faire
que nos semaines
orbitent autour
de dimanche
aujourd'hui
et qu'on sache
que la semaine
que Dieu nous a donnée
est une opportunité
pour faire
tout ce qu'on a fait
pour sa gloire
et revenir
les dimanches
devant Dieu
avec les mains remplies
des fruits
de justice
avec un bon témoignage
ayant vécu
une bonne représentation
de Dieu
dans la semaine
et réjouir pleinement
non seulement
de la contemplation
de Dieu
mais du privilège
que Dieu nous a donné
pendant cette semaine
d'avoir démontré
dans nos vies
aux personnes
combien Dieu
est adorable
est perçu
en moi
ok
on va devoir
s'arrêter ici
et on va
conclure
la semaine prochaine
avec les quatre états
de l'image
de Dieu
dans l'homme
et comprendre
comment nous pouvons
maximiser
l'image de Dieu
en nous
dans notre état
de renouvellement
spirituel
et on va
en nous